>> Suzanne Schadl: Good
afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress --
oh my gosh, that's so loud.
I have the privilege of
working with a tremendous team
of librarians in the Hispanic
Division, who work to improve
at best the diverse publications
written in Spanish, Portuguese,
English and many indigenous
languages of the Americas.
It is our collective honor
to welcome Mexican writer --
not just novelist,
Cristina Rivera Garza
and translators Suzanne
Jill Levine and Aviva Kana,
and our moderator Manuel --
>> Manuel Cuellar: Cuellar.
>> Suzanne Schadl: Cuellar.
I wanted to do that in
Portuguese, I'm sorry.
To discuss "The Taiga Syndrome",
the 2018 English
language translation
of Cristina Rivera Garza's
"El mal de la Taiga".
For the librarians in the
room this has nothing to do
with the Taiga Forum --
other than the reference
to far reaches.
It is important to
me to use this moment
to acknowledge Catalina
Gomez who is our curator
of the archive of Hispanic
literature on tape,
and the Hispanic Division
as well as Anya Creightney
and Rob Casper from the
Poetry and Literature Center-
And I just learned from Rob
that we have a connection
through the Huntington
endowment,
so thanks for that information.
Along with the Mexican
Cultural Institute
on the Dorothy Project,
these three individuals
have led efforts
to make this event possible,
of course, with our panelists.
Before I pass the microphone --
because we'd like to
pass the microphones
in these formal events, to
Anya Creightney program manager
and the Poetry and
Literature Center,
I'd like to share a
quote and a reference
to another work authored
by Cristina Rivera Garza.
It's called "The
Unusual Manifesto".
"Writing is a community-making
practice.
If we write, we write
with others, inescapably.
If we write, we write about
others, even when we write
about ourselves in small
diaries that remain hidden
and locked in drawers.
Constantly borrowing from the
language we share, with entire
and varied communities at once.
When we write, we acquire
debt, a real material debt,
with the practitioners
of such languages.
It is an immense debt.
The same could be said
about library work,
and its likely translation.
It is a community
making practice,
which we do with others,
describing and sharing writing,
always borrowing and
continually building
on an already enormous debt".
Thank you all for being part of
this community today and know
that you are welcome in
the Hispanic Division.
We'd love to tell you
more about what we do.
And with that, I will
pass the mic to Anya.
[ Applause ]
>> Anya Creightney:
Thanks, Suzanne.
We're thrilled to join forces
with this, but I just have
to say, this podium
is severe [laughter].
I can see just heads here.
Anyway, we're thrilled
to join forces
with the Hispanic Division.
It's a pleasure to
build such valuable work
with such committed and talented
colleagues, it's a real thrill.
As Suzanne mentioned, my
name is Anya Creightney,
I'm the program's manager at the
Poetry and Literature Center,
rather, which is
housed just upstairs.
Our lovely guests
here worked there
in that space earlier today,
and our center is charged
with highlighting the ongoing
and sustained value
of poetry and prose.
We're an important charge.
We celebrate all things literary
through public readings,
such as this one, lectures,
symposia, festivals,
along with a bevy
of online features,
most prominently the archive of
recorded poetry and literature,
which is sort of a
twin to the archive
that Suzanne just mentioned.
We're also the home of
the US poet laureate.
You may know this years'
laureate, Ms. Tracy K. Smith,
who is now on her second term,
and we just land
there's a connection.
Cristina has translated a
poem of Tracy's from "Life
on Mars" so, we're in
good company today.
This year Tracy is holding
reading and listening sessions
in rural communities
all over the country,
as part of her project
"American Conversations".
She's also just launched
a podcast in association
with the Minnesota Public Radio
and American Public Media,
titled "The Slowdown"
so, we encourage you
to please take a listen.
And of course, I've just
scratched the surface
of our center's offerings
rather so, please come back.
Come tomorrow to our events
and take a look online.
We're reachable at
loc.gov/poetry,
and you can also add your name
to the signup sheet by the door.
And I just want to say what
a thrill is to work, again,
with our colleagues here.
It's a deep pleasure for us to
honor writing and translation.
We feel strongly about it
and so, without further ado,
I want to hand it over to
my dear friend Catalina,
who is going to talk a
little bit about the flow
of the even today, and also
introduce our lovely guests.
Catalina.
[ Applause ]
>> Catalina Gomez:
Thank you, Anya.
Thank you, Suzanne.
We're just also --
I want to say I'm
so thrilled that Suzanne's here.
This is our second week as a
chief of the Hispanic Division
and we are just very excited
to welcome her to the library.
So, I'm Catalina Gomez, I'm
a reference librarian here
at the Hispanic Division.
I just want to say
that this event,
it was really cool
how it came about,
because Cristina was
actually doing research
in our reading room
here, I think for one
of her upcoming books.
Okay. And I was on my reference
duty and I saw her and I'm like,
"oh, you're Cristina
Rivera Garza.
We should do an event
with you here".
And it was a lot of fun and
we also love the division
to celebrate translation.
And we piled during the
Taiga Syndrome was going
to be published this year.
So, we thought it was
a perfect opportunity
to celebrate this book.
This is one of three events
that Cristina is doing
in Washington this week.
Tomorrow she has a lecture at
the Mexican Cultural Institute,
at 6:45p.m. It's actually going
to be in Spanish and it's going
to be about writing in
Spanish in the United States.
And this Friday October 19th
at 03:00p.m, at the University
of Maryland College Park she'll
be giving another lecture titled
"José Emilio Pacheco, our
great dissappropriationist".
For more information, check
out the Mexican Cultural
Institute's website
at www.instituteofmexicodc.org.
So, before we move
on to the program,
I just have some housekeeping
items and announcements.
If you all could please silence
your cellphones and we also want
to let you know that
we're filming the event,
so if you participate in the
Q&A session of the program,
you're giving the Library
of Congress permission
to have your voice on the video.
I also want to briefly announce
that Cristina is reporting
for our archive on
Hispanic literature on tape,
was recently made
available online.
Every September the Hispanic
Division releases 52 recordings
of this collection
for online streaming,
and this year's batch includes
Cristina's 2015 recording,
where she's actually reading
from the book we're
here to celebrate.
For those of you who don't
know about this archive,
it's a 75-year-old project that
we curate here at the library.
Consists of close to
800 audio recordings
of Luso-Hispanic poets
and writers reading
from their works.
It's passed 32 countries
and more than ten languages.
And we have recordings
with figures like Borges,
Gabriel Garcia Marquez,
Juan Rulfo,
Gabriela Mistral and many more.
We have a flyer about the
project, and again, so,
whoever's interested,
you can find out more.
And now on to the program.
That will consist of two
sections, a bilingual reading
where Cristina will be --
from the Spanish edition
of today's celebrated book
"El mal de la Taiga",
which was published
by Tusquets Mexico in 2013.
And then translators
Suzanne Jill Levine
and Aviva Kana will
read excerpts
from the English translation,
which was published this year
by the Dorothy Project.
The second portion will be a
conversation between Cristina,
Suzanne -- Suzanne
Jill and Aviva,
moderated by Manuel Cuellar
from the George Washington
University.
Cristina Rivera Garza
was born in Matamoros,
Tamaulipas, Mexico in 1964.
She's the author of six
novels, three collections
of short stories, five
collections of poetry
and three non-fiction books.
Her books have been translated
to multiple languages,
including English, French,
Italian, Portuguese and Korean.
She has a PhD from the
University of Houston,
at her dissertation from
the departure point for both
"Nadie me verá llorar", one
of her most golden novels,
and the historical non-fiction
book "La Castañeda",
on Mexico's most
infamous mental hospital.
After a few years
at the University
of California San Diego,
she's now a professor
of Hispanic studies of
the University of Houston,
where she has been spearheading
the first PhD program
in creative writing and Spanish.
The recipient of the
Roger Caillois Award
for Latin American literature,
as well as the Ana Serves Prize,
she's the only author who was
won the International Sor Juana
de la Cruz prize twice,
in 2001 for her novel
"Nadie me verá llorar",
translated into English
by Andrew Hurley as "No one
will see me cry", and again,
in 2009 for her novel
"La muerte me da".
Suzanne Jill Levine has received
many honors for her translations
of Latin American literature.
She's the author of "Manuel Puig
and The Spider Woman, his life
and fictions", and
"The subversive scribe,
translating Latin
American fiction".
Her editions include
the "Penguin
"paper bag classic series
of Jorge Luis Borge's
essays and poetry.
Aviva Kana is a PhD candidate
in Hispanic literature
at the University of
California Santa Barbara.
Her work focuses on Latin
American literature, gender,
translation, and
applied linguistics.
Her translations have been
published in "Review, Literature
and Arts of the Americas",
"PEN America",
"Latin American literature
today" and fiction.
And finally, Manuel
Cuellar, our moderator,
he's an assistant
professor of Spanish
and Latin American
literatures and cultures
at the George Washington
University.
His research and teaching
focuses on Mexican literary
and cultural studies,
with an emphasis
on race, gender and sexuality.
His current book
manuscript "Assemblages
of a festive nation,
queer embodiments
and dancing histories of
Mexico" studies dancing bodies
and public spaces, in order to
privilege movement as a means
to examine questions
of citizen formation
and national belonging.
Please join me in
welcoming our participants.
[ Applause ]
>> Cristina Rivera Garza: Hello.
Hello, everybody.
This has been already a great
great day, great touching.
I'm very grateful for
your generous welcoming
to this institution, to this
place that I really adore.
I spend many, many hours
in the research here.
And as Catalina was saying,
this, my forthcoming book,
is very much based on research
that I've conducted right here
in the documents of
this institution.
So, I feel absolutely privileged
and lucky to be here with all
of you, with the generous
people in Mexican Institute,
professors from the
University of Maryland,
and these two wonderful
translators I just adore,
Jill and Aviva, and we'll talk
about the whole process
in a little bit.
What I want to do right
now, I'm going to read
in Spanish a section on the
first book of these novel,
and a section also of the
seventh chapter of this novel.
They're not very long
chapters, and then Aviva
and Jill will be reading the
translation into English,
and then we'll get to
the conversation, okay?
"Lo mismo, que habían
vivido ahí, me dijeron.
Que esa era la casa,
y la señalaban con una especie
de timidez que bien podía
confundirse con el
respeto o con el terror.
Sus dedos apenas lograban
asomarse por las bocamangas de
unos abrigos pesados y negros.
El olor a carbón bajo sus
brazos, las uñas sucias,
esos labios tan resecos.
Sus pupilas, que se movían
con discreción hacia el objeto
señalado, no tardaban en
regresar a su punto de partida,
la mirada frontal.
¿Qué buscaba ahí en realidad?
Eso era lo que me preguntaban
sin atreverse a preguntar.
Y yo, que tampoco lo
sabía con exactitud,
acoplaba mis pasos a los suyos.
Y los seguía de regreso a
la comarca entre la nieve.
No era una casa.
Eso habría que decirlo
desde ahora.
Yo hubiera descrito lo que vi
esa mañana de inicios de otoño
como una cabaña, tal vez menos.
Una casucha.
Era, en todo caso,
una estructura habitacional
hecha de tablas de madera y
pedazos de cartón, y
abundantes ramas secas.
Tenía un techo, en
efecto, de dos aguas,
y un par de ventanas
que a falta de vidrio,
recubrían con un plástico
grueso y transparente.
Tenía el aire de ser
un último refugio.
Daba la impresión de que
más allá solo quedaban la
intemperie y la ley de la
intemperie y el cielo, muy azul,
tan alto, sobre la intemperie.
Recuerdo el frío.
Recuerdo el frío sobre todo.
Recuerdo las mandíbulas
apartadas,
los puños dentro
de los bolsillos.
Habían llegado ahí según mis
datos a inicios del invierno.
Lo había colegido así porque
la última comunicación que
emitieron había salido de una
oficina de telégrafos de un
poblado fronterizo, que
quedaba a unos 200 kilómetros
de distancia.
El telegrama, dirigido al hombre
que me había encargado la
investigación, afirmaba
escueta,
pero solo indirectamente, que
no pensaban regresar jamás.
Cuando decimos adiós, ¿qué
es lo que saludamos en realidad?
Tomé el caso porque siempre he
sentido una debilidad achacosa
por formas de escritura
que ya están en desuso.
El radiograma, la
taquigrafía, los telegramas.
Fue cosa de tocar el papel
amarillento y empezar a soñar.
Las yemas de los dedos sobre
las arrugas de la hoja,
el olor a viejo, algo guardado.
¿A quién se le hubiera
ocurrido hacer algo así?
A esos dos, por supuesto.
De entre todos, solo
a ellos dos.
¿Desde qué lugar tan
lejano en el espacio,
tan lejano en el tiempo
había partido este puñado
de mayúsculas?
Y, sobre todo, ¿qué
habían saludado en realidad?
¿Qué cosa o cosas habían
aceptado en sus vidas?
Quise saber eso desde el inicio.
Quise entender.
Recuerdo el lobo.
Vi, en efecto, un lobo
enorme y gris sobre la nieve.
Vi sus fauces abiertas,
sus ojos, sus garras.
Vi el hilo rojo que partía de
su huella y se deslizaba luego
entre la nieve, hasta enredarse
en el tronco del abeto.
Vi el abeto, majestuoso.
Trepaba entonces, el hilo
rojo por sus ramas compas,
por sus perennes hojas
aciculares hasta alcanzar en lo
alto las ramas verdes
de otra conífera.
Fue por eso que observé
el cielo, gris, también.
Repleto de gruesas
nubes abigarradas.
¿Cuál gris?
El gris de diez minutos antes
de la tormenta, naturalmente.
No oía, no podía
escuchar nada,
pero vi cómo el lobo
se preparaba para saltar
sobre algo.
Vi como la saliva, sus
dientes, sus labios".
I'm jumping to chapter seven.
"Algo de su lengua
en mi lengua".
"Que todo esto ocurría
a inicios de otoño,
haría falta aclararlo,
por ejemplo.
Que el viento entre
los cabellos,
gélido ya, o aproximándose.
Que la alberca, la curiosidad
que producía o el terror.
Una alberca en medio del
bosque y a través de la bruma,
¿qué cosa en realidad era eso?
Todas estas imágenes y luego el
largo trayecto hacia todas esas
imágenes que se llevó
a cabo, en efecto,
durante los últimos días del
verano que ya se convertían
poco a poco primero y de
súbito después en el otoño.
Antes, compré los boletos de
avión, los boletos de tren,
los boletos de barco o barcaza.
Hice reservaciones
de hotel, de hostal,
de cuartos pequeños cuando fue
posible hacerlo desde lejos,
electrónicamente.
Contacté amigos, que a su vez
se pusieron en contacto con
amigos, que poco a poco me
fueron aproximando a la tarea.
Hacía falta, como siempre
hace falta, un traductor,
un informante, y
mucho antes de llegar,
mucho antes de partir incluso,
tenía ya entre mis contactos
al hablante de su lengua que se
encargaría de ponerlo
todo en mi lengua.
Recuerdo las muchas frases
que repetí esa frase.
El hablante de su lengua que se
encargaría de ponerlo todo en
mi lengua.
La sonrisa que no la risa.
El gesto de intriga
o de desconsuelo.
El suspiro o esto, esta
otra cosa más serena.
En el informe que le escribiría
al hombre que había tenido dos
esposas, le pediría que tomara
en cuenta que nada de lo escrito
habría ocurrido tal cual.
Nada de lo escrito
ocurre nunca tal cual.
Repetiría eso o algo parecido.
Le pediría, de una cierta
manera cuidadosa y elegante --
asumiendo que él
estaría al tanto,
pero sabiendo también que
este tipo de cosas pasan
desapercibidas casi siempre.
Que tomar en cuenta que había
mucho tiempo entre alocución
y alocución.
'Deténgase', le pediría.
'Lea, como si hubiera muchos
minutos, incluso algunas horas,
entre las palabras
pronunciadas primero,
y luego las palabras escritas,
transcritas, las frases'.
Le diría, por ejemplo, que
cuando yo escribiera -- cito,
'les pregunté si tenían
electricidad y ellos me
respondieron mostrándome
una vela encendida'.
Debía considerar que la
pregunta la había enunciado yo,
en efecto, pero que antes
de recibir la respuesta,
que tardó en llegar,
el traductor tuvo que hacerme
repetir la pregunta un par de
veces, y luego tuvo que
enunciarla él también un par
de veces, hasta que los
habitantes de la comarca de la
última Taiga pudieron
entenderla,
y a su vez, contestarla.
Y luego, hubimos de esperar.
El traductor, los habitantes,
yo misma, a que la acción --
el hecho de mostrar
la vela encendida,
y el hecho de pronunciar a la
vez las palabras 'no tenemos
electricidad' pasara por el
entendimiento y luego por la
sorpresa, y finalmente
por la incredulidad.
Recuerdo la imagen del abismo.
Recuerdo, sobre todo,
las palabras 'fin del
mundo', todas juntas.
Las muchas imágenes
de mi propia ciudad,
ese sitio lleno de
espacios oscuros que había,
yo diría, dejado atrás.
El traductor me esperó en el
aeropuerto de la última ciudad
grande que visitaron antes de
internarse en los pequeños
poblados de la Taiga.
De ahí, de esa ciudad
fronteriza,
había salido el telegrama,
'nunca tan cerca lo lejos'.
Supuse que ellos habían
aterrizado en el mismo
aeropuerto y que abrochándose
el abrigo y enredándose la
bufanda en el cuello se habrían
dado algo de tiempo para mirar
el cielo".
"Nunca supe si eso
fue alguna vez cierto.
Nunca tuve idea de cuánto
tiempo les llevó conseguir el
chofer que los llevó,
¿a dónde?
Supuse que habrían dormido
ahí en esa ciudad de 200.000
habitantes, donde
se extrae petróleo,
pero no estaba segura de nada.
Lo único, de lo único
que sí tenía evidencia,
era que de esa ciudad había
partido un telegrama lleno
de mayúsculas.
Un telegrama y una
carta, también.
Una carta muy breve, escrita
a lápiz por una mano que se
presentía entumida o cansada.
Jamás lo lejos arremetió
tan cerca.
Las variaciones continuaban".
[ Aplausos ]
>> Aviva Kana: "'The thing that
lived there', they told me,
'in that house, there'.
And they pointed it out
with an apprehension
that could easily be
mistaken for respect or fear.
Their fingers barely
peeked out from the cuffs
of their heavy black coats.
The smell of ash under their
arms, dirty nails, dry lips.
Their eyes, having
discreetly moved towards
where they were pointing,
quickly returned
to their original position,
gazing straight ahead.
'What are you really
looking for?'
They asked, without
daring to say so.
And I, who didn't exactly
know, followed their steps
like a shadow, back
to the village
over snow-covered trails.
It wasn't really a
house, I should say first.
I would have described
what I saw on that morning
at the beginning of autumn
as a shack, maybe not even.
A hobble. In any case, it was
a habitable structure made
from wood, cardboard and
lots of dry branches.
It did have a roof,
a ridged roof,
and a pair of windows
covered in thick,
transparent plastic
instead of glass.
It had the air of a last refuge.
It gave the impression that
beyond was only open space
and the law of the
wilderness, and the sky so blue,
so high above the wild.
I remember the cold.
Above all, I remember the cold.
I remember my clenched jaw,
fists deep in my coat pockets.
They had arrived there
according to my information,
at the beginning of winter.
I had come to that conclusion
because their last communication
came from a telegram office
in a border town about
200 kilometers away.
The telegram, addressed to
the man who had hired me
to investigate the
case, said briefly --
and somewhat obliquely that
they were never coming back.
What are we letting in
when we say goodbye?
I took the case because I have
always had an all-consuming
weakness for forms of
writing no longer in use.
Radiograms, stenography,
telegrams.
As soon as I placed my hands
on the faded paper,
I began to dream.
The tips of my fingers skimmed
the creases of the paper,
the stale smell of
age, something hidden.
Who would set out
on such a journey?
Bad men, of course.
Out of everyone, only those two.
From what place?
So far away in space,
so far away in time.
Have his fistful of
capital letters, then sent.
And what were the two
of them hoping for?
What have they led
into their lives?
That was what I wanted
to know, from the start.
to understand.
I remember the wolf, I
saw him, an enormous wolf.
Grey against the snow, his
jaw open, his eyes, his paws.
I saw the red thread that
extended from his tracks,
and slither to the snow before
momentarily getting lost
in the trunk of a far tree.
I saw the fur, so majestic.
Then inclined, the red thread,
through the warped branches,
through the evergreen
pine needles until high
above it reached the green
branches of another conifer.
That was what made me look
up at the sky, also gray,
filled with thick,
jumbled clouds.
What shade of grey?
Ten minutes before
storm grey, of course.
I didn't hear anything,
couldn't hear anything,
but I saw that the wolf
was preparing to pounce.
I saw his saliva, teeth, lips."
[ Applause ]
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
"Tongue to tongue".
"Among other things, I
should explain that all
of this occurred at the
beginning of autumn.
That the wind blowing my hair
was icy, nearly freezing.
That the pool caused
curiosity -- or terror.
A pool in the middle
of the forest
through the mist,
how could this be?
All these images in the long
journey toward these images
ended, essentially, during
the last days of summer.
Already returning
little by little --
at first, then all
at once into autumn.
Before I had bought the plane
tickets, the train tickets,
the passage for the barge.
Whenever it was possible from
far away, electronically,
I had made reservations
at hotels
and hostels for single rooms.
I contacted friends who put me
in contact with their friends,
who little by little brought
me close to the tidal.
It was necessary, as
it is always necessary,
to find a translator, a guide.
So, long before I arrived and
even longer before I left,
I had among my contacts a
speaker of their tongue,
who would just transmit
everything into my tongue.
I remember how many times
I repeated the same phrase,
tongue to tongue, at the
speaker of their tongue
who would translate
everything into my tongue.
A smile, know, a laugh, a
look of intrigue or distress,
a sigh or something more serene.
In the report I would --
" should I continue this?
>> Yes.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
I continue?
>> Yes.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine: Oh.
"In the report, I would write
for the man who had two wives.
I would ask him to
take into account
that nothing had happened
exactly as I claimed.
I would tell him that nothing
happens as it is written.
I would constantly repeat
this, or something like it.
I would ask him in a
careful and tactful way,
assuming that he knew but
realizing also that these types
of things are as hard to bear
in mind, to take into account
that there is a great distance
between speech and writing.
'Take your time',
I would remind him.
Read as if there
are many minutes,
even hours before
the word spoken
and the ones written down.
'Transcribe, the phrases'.
I would tell him, for example,
when I wrote, 'I asked them
if they had electricity,
and they responded
by showing me a lit candle'.
That he should realize I had, in
fact, pronounced that question,
but before I received the
answer, which came much later,
the translator had made me
repeat the question several
times, and then had said
it several times himself
until the inhabitants
of the village
in the Taiga could
understand it and answer.
And then we had to wait,
translator, inhabitants, myself,
until the action
showing the candle
in articulate words 'we don't
have electricity' was heard
and understood first
with surprise
and then finally, disbelief."
[ Applause ]
>> Manuel Cuellar: Now
I have the privilege
of starting the Q&A.
Asking them some questions
and then I'll pass
the microphone along
for the questions you may have
about this wonderful reading.
I think this is a novel
that is such timely
and crucial, especially.
Considering issues
of translation
and translating women out
first, I was captivated by how,
Cristina, you engaged issues of
gender, writing, sexual labor,
constructive capitalism,
and ways of --
this is something I'm obsessed
with, ways of relating others
and relating to others.
And this is a lyrically
hunting work so,
thank you for that wonderful
reading of the three of you.
And the first question,
because, were talking
about the Taiga here, can you
please tell us how you first
conceived this project?
Just to get us started.
In other words, what
inspired you?
What led you to the Taiga?
>> Cristina Rivera
Garza: The Taiga is
such a faraway place, huh?
At least if we take into
consideration our position
in the globe right now.
I was thinking more
and more about scape.
And one of the challenges
that I wanted to go through
and I wanted to take
leaders with me,
was about how far away I could
get, in terms of the writing,
in terms of telling the story,
in terms of telling
a story of escape.
How far away I could
get with my readers, so,
at what point the story
might become unintelligible?
So, the challenge for me was
to move away as much as I could
from known, familiar
territory, and I was going
to approach places, languages,
landscapes as alien
to me as possible.
And I wanted to use language
that was able to embody
that strangeness, while
keeping my reader still with me,
while creating a
sense of strange,
unique familiarity between us.
I suppose that was
the main issue.
And I was living in
Mexico by then --
or most of the writing I
think, I lived in Mexico.
So, I guess the more faraway
place that I could think
of was the Taiga for, again,
mostly the winter,
that kind of winter.
>> Manuel Cuellar: I'm going
to ask you one more question
and then I'll get to
our translators then.
This is, as you've heard,
multi-sensorial creative work.
I think it really transcends
the written work, and if we look
at the different versions
of the translation
of the original work, the
original comes with drawings
by Carlos Maiques, and it
really enhances the sort
of atmosphere Cristina's
trying to capture.
But also, both editions come
with that so, just a playlist.
And I wanted her to know --
I was explaining this morning
for my students -- yes, what
they were thinking about this.
I wanted to find out
whether you could comment
on this creative process.
Do you think of the list first?
Because it really enhances
that sense of eeriness
that you certainly heard, right?
Did you think of it at the end,
or while you were writing it?
>> Cristina Rivera
Garza: Yes, thank you.
Thank you for those questions.
And yes, in fact, the original
version in Spanish comes
with some eerie drawings
that I really loved.
And then I kind of
decided not to include
that in the English version,
but perhaps in the second
edition we might be able
to include them.
I'm just annunciating
that right now.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine: We
try to convince them, right?
>> Cristina Rivera Garza: We
did, we did our best, yes.
That's what was for.
But let me see, I'm the
kind of writer who has
to be annunciating the
words that I'm writing
as I'm writing so, every time
that I'm writing in a room,
it sounds as there's a
conversation going on,
because I'm actually enunciating
out loud every single word.
And I think the reason why
I've been doing that is
because I want the words
to go through my body,
and I want to measure my
breathing pattern and try
to accommodate, to
fit all those words
within my own breathing pattern.
So, if I write a sentence that
is too long or too convoluted
and I'm not able to pronounce
that in a way that is pleasing
to my ear at that point
well, that sentence has
to go, obviously, right?
And so, I do that and because
of that I've gotten very used
to my own, very at ease with
my own breathing patterns.
And when I was writing this
book, and as I told you earlier,
I wanted to go through this
experience of unfamiliarity
and I wanted to take the reader
to these other faraway places
in terms of the landscape and
in terms of the writing as such,
this election of the writing and
the rhythm of the sentences and,
you know, the use of punctuation
signs and things like that.
So, what I said from the
beginning I need to interrupt,
I need to interfere my
own breathing patterns
with something else.
And so, I look for some of these
songs and some of these pieces
and some of them have words
in them and stories in them.
But many of those are
just instrumental.
Some of those are a
collection of electronic music,
contemporary music, some
music from the area as well.
And I used to play them as I
was writing these different
chapters, and I wanted to
pay very close attention
to their own rhythms and
the sounds and the words,
and I wanted to have these
external elements interfering
with my own breathing patterns.
So, if I wanted to embody
that sense of unfamiliarity,
of being in a foreign territory,
I assumed that by doing
that I was also placing myself
in the writing process as such
in that foreign territory
as well.
But I think the songs
are really good too,
and some of the videos
are actually quite good.
And so, there was
also that connection
between what I was
imagining and the kind
of landscape I was trying
to convey in this piece.
>> Manuel Cuellar: Wonderful.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
You actually translated one
of the titles, because
the ritual reality,
was ritual virtuality.
>> Cristina Rivera
Garza: Is that right?
>> Suzanne Jill Levine: Yes, and
I thought that was interesting
that you unconsciously did that.
I, myself, feel very
irresponsible
because I didn't listen to these
until after I translated
[laughter].
I know, because I know.
>> Cristina Rivera Garza: The
second edition [laughter].
>> Suzanne Jill Levine: I
mean, that's what we have
to do, a second edition.
>> Manuel Cuellar: I actually
wanted you to share with us
and the audience
a little bit more
about the process
of translating.
How do you decide to
translate this novel?
And part of the question
has to do with the political
and ethical states of
translating from Spanish
to English, and also
questions of the market,
since we'll be talking
about the editor,
whether it include the
drawings, etcetera, right?
And how that shaped your
ability to translate
and publish these
creative works.
And I'm thinking specifically
of this Dorothy Project,
the publisher who
focuses on women writers.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine: Yes,
they are wonderful small press.
They've done Nails
Inc., for example.
They choose very -- oh.
They choose their
writers very carefully.
Oh, now it's on.
They choose their
writers very carefully.
Does that make a difference?
I'm pretty loud anyway.
Okay, maybe that's a
better one here, well.
Oh [laugher].
Well, you heard me
anyway, I said, yes.
So, it's a very wonderful small
press, and I mean, just thinking
about small presses --
I'm just jumping in here.
They really amazingly survived
and have proliferated
despite the market place being
so challenging.
So, it's something
really to admire.
>> Aviva Kana: Oh, I was
just going to jump in.
Well, maybe I don't wish
I had a better answer,
but originally I wanted
to translate a different
book of Cristina's.
>> Manuel Cuellar: Which one?
>> Aviva Kana: "La
cresta de Ilión", yes.
"The Iliac Crest", I originally
contacted her about that book,
and some of us were
already translating it
and she sent me this
book or, you know, said,
"what about this one?"
So, I immediately
sat down and read it.
So, it's sort of random I guess,
which I think kind of fits
with the type of
book and I said,
"all right, I'm going to do it".
And then one thing
I wanted to say just
about what Cristina was saying
about reading it out loud,
I found that really interesting,
because I don't know
how many people
in coffee shops I harassed
trying to get them to listen
to a certain sentence that
I was saying in my head
and I just had to
say it out loud.
I know you think with
translation you have to say it
out loud, it just bounces
around in your head.
It just doesn't work.
So, yes, a lot of talking
to myself but then a lot
of coffee shop harassment
and harassment
of friends [laughter].
Whoever would listen.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
Yes so, that began --
and it really began as
Aviva's project, right?
And you were doing that also
for your emphasis, right?
Your work as your doctoral.
So, it didn't began
as a marketplace --
>> Manuel Cuellar: Wonderful.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
It worked as an academic
and intellectual project, and
then Dorothy Project somehow --
I don't know how they stepped
in, but they stepped in --
>> Aviva Kana: I sent it, yes.
But Cristina had recommended
that publisher and I had sent it
to some places before
and it came
that it really was
a pretty ideal fit
which is their mission
statement.
I could see it could be
written about your writing.
>> Cristina Rivera Garza:
I was pretty familiar
with the Dorothy project.
Is a press that I love the
canon, I love the authors
and I read several of the
conferences, especially the work
by Renee Gladman, and I was
thinking, "if this work belongs
in any press in the United
States it would be that one".
So, from the very beginning I
thought about Dorothy Project
and I was very settled that
one, and Aviva was asking me,
"where should I send it?"
I said, "well, the Dorothy
Project, obviously".
And so, it turned out that
it was a good call, yes.
>> Manuel Cuellar: Is that
why you chose this book
in particular?
>> Cristina Rivera Garza:
Yes, because there's the one
that I find the catalogue,
the conversation
that they are engaging with
in terms of experimentation
and cross gender writing, in
terms of writing of women,
not only from the United States
but also from other places.
And in addition to that,
they have been recently
translating the work
by Leonora Carrington, which
is of my also favorite writes,
who is not from Mexico but lived
in Mexico, but was from Uruguay.
>> Manuel Cuellar: I wanted
Jill and Aviva to share
with us your approach
to translation,
but then I mean your method
or theory, and what it was
like to translate this work?
>> Suzanne Jill Levine: Well,
again, the project began
with Aviva, and,
you know, for me,
translation is editing anyway.
So, I mean, that's
what writing is too,
writing is rewriting,
it's editing.
So, I sort of stepped in
as the director, I suppose,
on the academic setting of the
project, but also as an editor.
And so, you know,
obviously we talked
about sound, rhythm, language.
I was looking to make this --
because when you look
at Cristina's writing,
it actually has impact.
I mean, in other words,
you'll straight something
is very concise, and so,
I felt that the English
had to be very tight,
and at the same time
have sensuality,
have images that
were very clear.
So, it was a very
difficult project.
I mean, maybe we should talk
about some of our challenges,
the specific challenges.
And I think maybe you want
to begin with what you liked,
but I know that what made
Cristina very happy was
when we came up with
"tongue to tongue",
because that originally said,
"something in his tongue",
"algo en su lengua"
-- ¿cómo is that?
Algo en su lengua
que -- ¿cómo es?
>> Manuel Cuellar: "Algo
de su lengua en mi lengua".
>> Suzanne Jill Levine: So,
"algo de su lengua
en mi lengua", okay.
To me it was suggestive.
In other words --
>> Manuel Cuellar:
Yes [laughter].
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
Language into language, okay.
But wait a minute.
You know, "something
into something" --
so, basically "tongue"
had to be there, right?
Mother's tongue or whoever's
tongue had to be there.
And, you know, it says,
in English, something --
it's weak, but it says,
"tongue to tongue",
I think the reader gets the
idea, and then, of course,
you see the repetition
of the phrase
as the phrase was
in the text, right?
So, I think titles
are very curious.
The titles of her
chapters are amazing.
I mean, she has a
sense of humor.
I know she reads very serious
but she's very sensed in humor.
"Muy serio", says over here.
The thing is, but
she's very funny.
And so, these titles
are sharp and funny,
and I think that that
had to come through
and you read a chapter or --
you read a book through
its title so,
in some ways the title
is very important,
which comes to "El
mal de la Taiga".
We could've call it "the
disease of the tiger"
or "the tiger disease",
but you know,
first of all it sounds
like "tiger".
Well, the tiger's disease?
What's going on?
But the thing is I used "the
syndrome" and it was so perfect.
Because first of
all I was thinking
of "the China syndrome",
which of course has all the
implications of capitalism
and this corruption,
the technology, ecology,
all that sort of problem.
Ecological disaster so,
the idea of syndrome came,
and of course, it's a disease.
So, you see these so-called
"changes", they're translations,
it's like writing the text
so, that it is as impactful
as it is in the original.
>> Aviva Kana: Yes, I think a
lot of it has to do with balance
and Jill and I have
talked about this a lot.
It's just that because
everything, by necessity has
to be changed up and modeled
around, then there's sort
of an aspect of, "well,
we're losing this so,
we're putting something
else in",
sort of a constant push
and pull with that.
And it's not always
the exact, same thing,
because sometimes you
can't or you don't want
to for whatever reason because
it have the different languages
function, but then maybe
in the next paragraph,
maybe it's repetition of
something else but you want
to hold that repetition.
One of the challenges was
definitely the word "that",
which -- we all talked
about that a lot.
It's a huge one,
it's one little word,
but it was a huge
one issue because --
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
When I first looked
at the text, I said --
>> Aviva Kana: So
many "that's" --
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
There's too many "that's" there.
That.
>> Aviva Kana: And there were
and, I mean, the problem is,
of course that in English
we just have one "that"
and in Spanish you
have multiple so,
what in Spanish would be three
different words in one sentence,
was something ending up being
the same word three times very
quickly, and yet at the
same time, the use of "que"
in Spanish is indispensable.
That's everything,
so much of the book
because it's this being told
that this happened, that --
you know, and it cannot be taken
away, but it read really heavy
in English because we use
"that" just all over the place.
So, that I thought
was tiny, but huge.
>> Cristina Rivera Garza:
And it was important that --
for me, at least, that you
have kept it exactly as it was
in Spanish, because this
indirect speech is central,
is fundamental for the story.
I wanted to emphasize mediation,
the filtering of information,
how knowledge is being produced
at every stage of the story,
and so, in order to do that in
Spanish we use "que", right?
This is indirect speech
and there is no other
way around that.
But then, yes, there were
too many "that's" [laughter].
>> Suzanne Jill Levine: But it
was very important to have that,
it was the first word
search [laughter].
>> Aviva Kana: I did a
text search at one point
and just started
to take them out.
>> Cristina Rivera Garza: On
the other hand, I'm very happy
that you had actually caught
my great sense of humor.
Actually people don't
believe that.
I'm with you [laughter].
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
I know, I know.
>> Manuel Cuellar: I
wanted to ask you, Cristina,
and the translators whether you
collaborated this time around.
You surprised us last
time with the Iliac Crest
because you did collaborate
a lot right under that.
>> Cristina Rivera
Garza: Yes, yes.
Last year the Feminist
Press published
"The Iliac Crest"
translated by Sarah Booker,
and in just a said word with
Jill and Aviva very closely
in the translation, I
did the same with Sarah.
"The Iliac Crest" is a
novel that I published
in Spanish originally in 2003.
And so, many years had passed
from the original publication
to the moment of
the translation.
And so, when I was reading
the English version,
I thought that if I were
writing that book at this point,
I would've added
some more paragraphs.
And just the thought
crossed my mind and --
obviously, and I
talked to the editor,
to Lauren at the Feminist
Press and she said, "well,
it's your book, you
know" [laughter].
"You can do whatever
you want", and I said,
"you shouldn't say that".
There were too many ideas
in my mind, and so, I did.
I added a series of paragraphs,
I altered some sentences
and in all that, I wrote
originally in English,
and then went back
into the Spanish.
So, the situation has become
really interesting now
because the book is being
republished this year in Mexico,
and so they had to translate
the paragraphs that I had added
in English, now they're being
translated back into Spanish.
And the book is kind of like the
same, but not necessarily so.
It's been updated in a
radical way, I suppose.
But my idea was that I have
to be true to the moment
of the reading, I have to be
true to the spirit of the book,
and I do look that
writing is a living entity,
and is never finalized.
If I were able to, I will be
writing these books forever.
Thankfully I'm not
able to do that
and I change from book to book.
And so, that happened
with "Iliac Crest".
And with these we
worked very closely.
We were emailing each other
almost daily at times.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
We were pestering her
basically [laughter].
>> Cristina Rivera Garza: And
I don't know where the day
that we came up, you came up
with this "tongue to tongue"
and I was like, "man, this is
exactly what I wanted to say".
It has to sound like in
English, and we had several
of those findings throughout
the process, so, it was fun,
it was complicated --
complex, I should say.
But it was all in all a
very friendly exchange,
and I think we all were open
about suggestions that came
from all over the place.
A lot of work, that's for sure.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine: And
I think it's interesting.
Did you translate the
English of the Iliac Crest,
those added paragraphs
back into Spanish or not?
>> Cristina Rivera
Garza: No, I didn't.
Someone else did.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
How do you feel about that?
>> Why?
[ Laughter ]
>> Cristina Rivera Garza:
The short answer was
that I was extremely busy,
and I didn't have time
and the press was on
a very tight deadline,
and so they needed that
for, like, yesterday,
and I was like, "I
just can't do it".
But I think the other
translator did a good job.
I had a chance to go
over that so, yes.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine: The
other thing I was going to say
that what you said after
we read the translation,
our translation,
you said, "you know,
in some ways I'm finally
understanding this
book" [laughter].
Which shows that you're still
involved in writing it, right?
And the other thing that you
said, which relates to that,
that actually seems more
alive what now you mention
that you wanted to make it
as far away as possible.
In some ways you were also,
in some ways thinking of it
in English a little bit.
And a couple of times we
ran into phrases like,
"para decir lo menos",
to say the least --
which is something
we say much more --
I'm just saying it's
very common in English.
And even though we say it in
Spanish too, I think it sort
of comes from English
a little bit so, yes.
>> Cristina Rivera Garza: This
is something interesting to me
that I was thinking about
as a shocking finding,
that many of these books,
it looks they have been --
are in translation now,
I conceived of them
in this country while working
in English, while reading a lot
of literature in English, and
many of the references and many
of the authors that I was
reading very carefully were
authors that belonged
to divisions
that are not necessarily
linked or that linked
to Latin American literature.
So, what happened to me
when I first started to talk
about Iliac Crest in
translation into English was
that the questions and the
conversations were so much
like the ones that I had hoped
I could've have in Spanish
but never have, because it
was read with different eyes,
it was inscribed in a
different tradition.
And the reading was good, and it
was very fruitful and all that
but it was not necessarily
the one that I had in mind.
But now that the book was in
translation, it seems to me
that the book was kind of coming
back to its original language.
So, I had thought of it while
maintaining a conversation
with certain experimental
tradition in the United States,
and I think many of the clues
who responded to that interest,
which might have been kind
of obscure for readers,
reading in Spanish and
in Mexican tradition
or in Latin American tradition.
And I think the same thing is
kind of happening with the Taiga
and this Taiga Syndrome.
And I became aware of the
situation in a conversation
about the Iliac Crest in the
university in San Francisco,
and one of the professors there
said, "well, this resembles
or it reminds me of" -- and he
mentioned two or three authors,
and I was, "well, exactly".
I mean, those were the ones that
I was trying to engage with.
And it was so clear
and so direct.
And so, the very
idea of translation
of what is the original language
of the book came
totally into place.
So, perhaps this is a
translation of the translation.
We have the original languages
[ Laughter ]
>> Manuel Cuellar: Now we can
open it up to the public and see
if anyone has questions.
And we have a microphone
going around.
>> Can you just tell us
what those two books were
that the professor counted?
[Laughter]
>> Cristina Rivera Garza: Let
me see, it was mostly poetry.
I do read a lot of poetry.
I mostly read poetry,
I should say.
And I don't want to lie to
you, and I'm bad with titles,
but they were poets, it
must have been something
like Linka Genien [phonetic].
It must have been something
like Rae Armantrout.
That kind of west coast
experimental writing, yes.
>> I have a question about
translating the senses,
because I think that's something
that's very interesting,
and your work, and a
lot of Mexican work
that I think it's sort
of an indigenous thing,
is the capturing senses.
So, you showed the
visuals in the book,
you talked about the sound
and the importance of sort
of feeling the sounds
in your body and I think
that multiple senses
started to come
out in both the translation
and in Spanish.
And I wondered if all of
you could talk a little bit
about translating senses,
because I think that's
another --
language is one thing and
is oral, and guttural,
but translating that
into written word
and then translating that
from the languages is very --
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
Well, you're going back --
>> It's an interesting skill.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
You're going back
to the original discussion
of translation,
which goes all the way
back to Saint Jerome,
and it has a biblical
translation.
Rather to really bring out
the true meaning of the book,
not word for word
but sense for sense.
So, this is like a foundational
idea in the discourse
on translation to being
with, so, you know.
>> Cristina Rivera Garza:
And that's especially
important for someone like me.
I believe in the writing
is an embodied practice.
It's not something that we
do right here, it's something
that we're doing, a whole body
and perception is absolutely
essential right there.
And touching those poems and
investigating the language
that might convey and may
make these points shareable
with others I think that's
very much the challenge
of every writing practice.
>> Aviva Kana: I
also think it's part
of what made this translation
really fun, that it kind of has
that double translation aspect
where you have to be thinking
about these different
elements --
and it goes back to what Jill
was saying about preserving kind
of the impact, because I
think the senses is sort
of about how it hits you
and where it hits you
as a reader as well.
And so, I think that
is definitely part
of what made it an
interesting translation.
I was thinking about that and I
think, you know, there was a lot
of times where you feel it
in your body while
you're translating it
and while you're reading
it and paying attention
to that as a translator.
Kind of 'how am I viewing this?'
is definitely a different
experience.
And it was a nice change
from other academic work
that I was doing at the time,
was that this was so visceral.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine: In some
way it's the essential academic
work too in some
way, because I mean,
it's the closest reading you
can give, and this is one
of the things where academia
has been very slow to realize,
how essential to the humanities
translation is in the concept
of its relationship to reading.
But just thinking of sense, for
a sense in one of the problems
that we had, which
was a huge one.
Throughout the book there
are certain sentences,
which are echoed, from time
to time they're repeated
and it sort of really had to do
a lot with the trust of the book
which is sort of understand
but don't understand
but you do understand.
It's one of those kind of senses
was, "cuando decimos adiós,
¿qué es lo que
saludamos en realidad?"
Now, think about that.
What does she really mean?
What is the sense?
So, we went through a lot
of different versions
of that, right?
>> Aviva Kana: I think we
ended up going back to one
of our earlier versions,
we -- yes.
We got around.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
And we often do that,
which is one thing that
I think you noticed,
that you sometimes go back
to an original version,
but what we said there and,
you know, what are we letting
in when we say goodbye?
Which is sort of
metonymically --
letting is kind of a
metonymic relationship
to saludar, because you greet.
But is very interesting.
I thought it was
quite difficult.
>> Manuel Cuellar:
And I'm just going
to give you a quick example
while we have the microphone.
One word that really
captivated me was
"entrecortadamente",
which is an adverb.
And you translate it
as "breathlessly".
It's an adverb with rhythm.
I thought it was very powerful.
The whole idea of
"entrecortadamente" versus
"breathlessly" which is
why you embodied that.
It's the same concept, right?
>> Suzanne Jill Levine: You
know who taught us that?
Borges [Laughter].
Borges taught many writers
things, and I learned a lot
when I looked at his
translation of Virginia Wolfe.
Because he translates basically,
he realized that English is
so much more elegant in terms
of adverbs, because "tedioso" is
like "heavymente"
in Spanish, right?
So, basically he would translate
the adverb into an adjective,
to avoid that "mente"
so, for example,
I think the sentence was, "she
grinned at him triumphantly" --
he said, "le hacía
muecas triunfales".
You see? And it's much
more elegant and tighter.
So, you see that?
But that's very interesting
that you brought that example.
That's one of those grammatical
problems that's very strong
between English and Spanish.
I mean, very problematic.
>> Manuel Cuellar: Albert?
>> I'd like to [inaudible]
your take on -- usually --
at least in my case, always
you're supposed to read a book,
if you can, in the language
that it was written originally.
But a translation is like re
writing a book and sometimes,
for example -- let's
put an example,
in "Memorias de Adriano" by
Cortázar from the French
to Spanish is so beautifully
translated that I'm pretty sure
that it's like reading
a different book.
What is your take on this?
Shall we read you in English?
Shall we read you in Spanish?
Is it two different
versions of the same?
>> Cristina Rivera Garza: Yes.
You know, I've done
some translating myself,
and I've learned a lot
from the experience.
I truly believe that a
translation is the version,
is the autonomous,
independent version of the book.
And in this case, and in
the case of the Iliac Crest
with Sarah Booker's translation,
I was recommending everybody
to read both, Spanish and
English, and it had nothing
to do with the market
[laughter], I swear,
but the work of the
translator is just
that there's this faithfulness,
but at the same time,
it's this radical transformation
that when it is done
as beautifully as Jill
and Aviva have done it,
in such a complex way, getting
to the heart of the matter,
I was not kidding
when I said at the end
that I was finally understanding
some other aspects of the book,
in which I think the
translation is quite successful.
They are giving me a gift.
I'm receiving a new book.
It's related to mine
in very precise ways,
in very faithful ways,
but at the same time,
it is a totally different
experience.
So, now that I have been reading
this book out loud in English
in some of these readings,
I'm always thinking of that
by things that I
was not expecting.
And finding the new version
enticing and alluring
and teaching me something
about my own writing
that I didn't notice -- that
I hadn't been able to notice,
and I think because of
the process of translation
and the conversation
that came with it.
So, I'm absolutely
grateful to these two,
and as I said earlier,
I just adore them,
and the conversation was
fun and it was rewarding.
And I don't know what
you think about that.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine: Well,
two things that I wanted
to mention to Hadrian -- and
of course Aviva and it was
that in the subversive
scribe that one
of the main points I make
is that translation --
if it is a good translation
and fulfills a potential.
In other words, it brings
out something that is
in the original but in a
different way, and then it sort
of kind of gives it
a light afterwards.
But you have to think that maybe
all writing it's translation.
I mean, Hadrian after all is
wonderful Marguerite Yourcenar,
she wrote it in French,
and I read it in English,
which I think she collaborated
in with her partner,
Grace Frick, her name was,
who did the English version.
But when I was reading that
book, I was thinking, "well,
this feels like it's Hadrian.
I feel like I'm hearing
the voice of Hadrian".
I mean, curiously I
didn't know it was English.
Also when we see these
British films that are based
on Shakespeare and stuff -- yes,
I mean, Shakespeare is based
on roman stories
and stuff like that.
But it's always the Brits
playing the ancient Greeks
and stuff, but nonetheless,
it felt to me
like I was hearing Hadrian as
well as Marguerite Yourcenar --
even though she had written
in French so, I mean,
in some ways the writing is a
translation of a translation
because there's always a
text underneath and so,
that's part of the
idea, I think.
>> Cristina Rivera Garza: I
do read a lot in translation.
By the way, I'm sorry.
But a lot in translation,
actually the best
book I read this year,
and I highly recommend,
is by this Danish author,
Madame Nielsen, and the
title of the book is
"The endless summer", and one
of the reasons why I love
this book is the quality
of the sentences
is just so amazing.
They're long sentences, almost
like Spanish-like sentences,
with a wonderful use
of punctuation signs
and the sound -- and everything
is perfect, and I was thinking,
"I'm reading this,
this is a translation".
I have no idea -- I don't
speak Danish, of course,
I have no idea about how the
sentences are like or sound
like in the original
language, but the translation
as such is just -- I don't
want to read it in Danish.
Well, because I don't
know Danish [laughter].
>> Aviva Kana: And I was
just going to say that yes,
it was a real privilege to
be working with an author
who wasn't possessive
over her writing.
A lot of times when we would
send something, I would be kind
of predicting, "oh, we may
have gone too far with this,
this is where there's
going to be an issue",
maybe there would
probably be an issue,
but it was somewhere
completely different.
It was always surprising kind of
the spots where it wasn't like,
"oh, a lot of liberties
were taken here,
this is what she's going
to send back and be
like 'this is not
what I wrote'",
and that was not really
something that you did.
And it was more like something
else so, it was always kind
of a surprising read
from Cristina as well,
and whenever I would
assume something,
I was pretty much
wrong with that.
Which was great, because then
there was a certain liberty
with that of how we
were able to experiment
as well as translators.
>> Cristina Rivera
Garza: But you know what?
I was not always like this.
I have to tell you,
I have to be honest.
When a novel of mine was
translated back in 2003,
"No one will see me cry",
I just gave my translator
such a hard time, because I had
not translated myself anything.
I hadn't gone through the
process of translation,
and I was way more possessive
about the meaning of things.
I was not that bad,
I'm exaggerating.
Before I embarked
in this translation
and also the Iliac Crest,
I had translated some works
by Vanessa Placeman,
Robert Peterman,
and I translated
recently the work
by this poet, Fred Mountain.
And so, I had myself
gone through that.
And that has just changed so
much the way in which I think
of my own work, my
relationship with the language
and just the carefulness,
devotion that goes
through every single decision
in this process of translation.
So, it's good.
>> Aviva Kana: The
right moment, yes.
>> Suzanne Jill Levine:
We learned a lot though --
I mean, there are
points that, you know,
you made also that helped us.
I mean, for example, indirect
discourse should be able
to strange and emphasizing
that was really important.
>> Manuel Cuellar:
Well, please join me
in thanking our great panelists.
[ Applause ]
>> Rob Casper: Yes.
I can only -- can you hear me?
Wait a second, there we go.
I can only say the same thing.
Thank you Manuel, for moderating
that wonderful wild panel.
Thanks to all of you
for your great work
on behalf of literature.
I'm Rob Casper, I'm the head of
the poetry and literature center
and before I let you
go, just a couple
of things I want to tell you.
First of all, I'm sure you all,
like me, want to get a copy
of "The Taiga Syndrome".
It is in the back.
I'm sure that all three of our
great writers, translators,
will sign copies so, please
get one, get more than one.
Give it to everyone you know.
Secondly, you should
have a survey.
We'd love to have
you fill this out.
It's really helpful for
us to know what kind
of programs we should be doing
and how we can improve
our programs.
So, you met Anya and
Catalina and Angel,
is right there, she
was with the mic.
You can give the
surveys to anyone of us,
we'd love to have your
comments, especially we'd love
to know how you might
have already engaged
with the library.
There's a little bit in the
bottom there you can fill out.
Finally, we hope to see
you back here very soon.
On Wednesday November
7th, at the same time
in the same room we have an
event co-sponsored by the Poetry
and Literature Center,
and the Hispanic division,
featuring Uruguayan poetry,
and we hope you can make it.
So, until then, enjoy.
[Applause]